i'll be honest with you i i know it
shouldn't be about me but what's the
name of the show right well it's the
rich
i'm just feeling an old man i'm an old
man
i remember when he was you know first
came in the league in 2009
and now he's uh after 13 remarkable
years and now joining us here on the
rich isaac show i remember interviewing
him before he's getting drafted
back in 2005 and he retired last year
after 16 terrific years in the nfl now
joining us here on the rich eisen show
courtesy of you can we'll talk about
that with alex smith here on the program
how have you been alex smith
rich i'm doing awesome man how you doing
long time no long time no talk it has
been that long i thought it was me i
think again i know it shouldn't be about
me but i thought did i do something
wrong alex did i do anything wrong i did
not absolutely not you know what i feel
like as you get older and you get
playing you know especially the
quarterback and there's there's a lot of
you know obviously obligations and
things you have to do you do for me
and as i had kids and family you get
good it just kind of when you have when
you can kind of you know disappearing
into your privacy and uh yeah it has
been too long yeah good to be on the
show good to be back how is it like to
be around the fam how's it like for you
alex you know it's been amazing like my
uh i'm incredibly lucky like my kids are
amazing ages uh my boys are you know
basically almost eleven and nine my
daughter's six and that was really kind
of the impetus of me
retiring last year
uh
you know in a lot of ways i'm even
physically better than i was a year ago
and but just you know my your family
ends up sacrificing so much uh for your
career you know we moved across the
country you know obviously football
not just on a daily but an annually
thing kind of just
dominates our calendar it dictates
everything life as we know it
and
um you know they had they'd sacrificed
for that long and so finally i felt like
it was you know it's time it's time to
uh to be a dad
um
focus on them you know they're in you
know obviously very impressionable ages
and just be a husband and so it was it
was the right time so i'm excited about
it still trying to figure it out though
you got any suggestions
well so you haven't had like that brady
moment so you didn't have that brady
moment six weeks since saying you know
what i can do this later on i gotta go
back to playing football you didn't have
that you know that moment alex no uh
obviously no obviously not enough uh to
to act on it you know it's funny i feel
like
yeah i could see him grappling with the
same things you know here he is he's
done this for 22 years same thing his
kids getting older and
you know they've all sacrificed a lot
and you could see him grappling with
that in the
you know the end of this last season and
then obviously the you know whatever it
was couple weeks he was retired and then
back
um because then also a chance to like
once it's gone it's gone right and he
you know maybe he has one more year and
you don't ever want to look back with
regret as well so
you do you do toil with all those those
those you know factors and trying to
make a decision and i'm personally
pumped he's coming back
you know like we've just never seen
anything like him and what he's doing
and then to still have a career here
like he did last year was it was bananas
on top of it so selfishly i'm excited to
see him play one more year at least so
uh i think it's amazing for football and
again it's just historic yeah think of
it alex smith i mean when you got
drafted it was just mere year five for
tom brady that was it yeah exactly you
know and he's like benjamin button i
mean i i've got a chance to be around
him more and more i'm like not only like
from a football just playing perspective
yes
you know we all have kind of arcs and
you certainly declines at the end we've
seen a lot of them you know you look at
drew brees and big ben at the end these
hall of fame careers that you know
like
tom just tom just in some ways i think
he's better i mean you know he never was
like a fleet of foot anyway and uh he
can still throw the ball all over the
field he's obviously incredibly smart he
takes care of his body and then he and
then i even you know you get around him
and i'm like
he just
his skin his hair like the guy just is a
good
defined uh
you know time so uh he's an anomaly
that's for sure so um what do you you
know uh i've got alex smith again here
on the uh the rich eisen show so did you
get a call i mean you see you're feeling
good did you get a call i mean because
um it it just seems like anything goes
right now at the quarterback position
regardless of who's on what team or or
anything like that and and
and yolo's shots are being taken all
over the place um did you get any phone
calls to say do you want
no phone calls i still talk to obviously
a lot of coaches that i have great
relationships with that are still
coaching and around the league and you
know uh but no it's that it's i i leave
it in arm's length it's not something
i'm thinking about at all uh loving
taking on this kind of next chapter
trying to figure out what i'm doing next
and uh but no i'm
i have fun i have fun
you know running routes for my kids and
playing catch with them and um
that's the extent of my football these
days uh alex smith uh here on the rich
eisen show so how do you think
andy reid is going to
um
fix
what happened last year
uh offensively
without tyree kill now how do you think
that's gonna work out in your former
place of business alex yeah you know uh
flat out like
you're not going to replace him
there's literally only one tyra killed
in the whole nfl i mean he is he is that
kind of difference maker you know i was
fortunate enough to play my last two
years there in kansas city with him and
he honestly when he's on the field it
just
the defense plays differently uh he
opens up so many other players around
him because everybody's so fearful and
there's a lot of fast guys in the league
that are very
you know in the end they're kind of
one-dimensional
tyrique is not that i mean we saw it
throughout the playoffs catch and run
catching the deep ball put him back
there punt kickoff return hand him the
ball in the backfield like i mean he's
an incredible weapon
um incredibly unique and he's just not
going to fill those shoes and and so
there will be
i i do think they won't be as dynamic on
offense this is the trade-off that i
think andy's thinking about
you know and and brett beach as they're
looking at it as well
you know for that salary that they were
potentially going to get him you know
and the draft picks that they got in
return can they go be better on the
defensive side of the ball you know like
i i think they look back to you know a
few years ago is maybe they're going to
be a little more balanced offense and
defense
they're going to get draft picks in
return and then i also think this is
this has kind of been andy's mo his
entire coaching career is that
rather than let you play out your
contract and walk away for nothing i
mean he's certainly gonna try and get
value for you while he can and certainly
i mean i was even a product of that
right like you mean how many
quarterbacks have we seen him do this
with over the years where
he does trade him and gets value back
and then he can go you know they do a
great job of developing talent so they
got all these picks for tyreek i know
they were trying to get him resigned
because he is so special um but
obviously the numbers just didn't quite
make sense and they decided to make this
move and it's bold and again they're not
going to replace him on offense i mean
you're not going to find anybody you're
not going to find anybody in the draft
out there in free agency that's gonna
fill those shoes so they're gonna have
to adjust a little bit offensively but i
think the big question is maybe as a
team can they be better from it right
that cap space can they go get some
other players maybe on the defensive
side of the ball with those draft picks
can they get some role players come in
and help them this next year i think
that's what they're that's the equation
they're trying to uh
you know make right um but it certainly
won't be they they will not be as
explosive as they have been on offense
period with tyrique on you just can't
you know he doesn't he's just that kind
of player what words of advice alex
smith would you have for carson wentz
going to washington now
oh man
that
it's tough you know i i mean
i think you got to try to eliminate the
noise there you know there's a lot of
noise um there's a lot of distractions
that entire organization
um everything surrounding it
um
and and
and and obviously deservedly that it's
been flawed the last 20 years there's a
lot of there's a lot of stuff going on
there a lot of distractions and it makes
it difficult to kind of focus in on on
the football um but i think carson's
kind of in
that's where he's at at this point in
his career this is really kind of make
her break he's getting one more chance
uh to kind of be the guy
um this is a team that you know has been
you know almost desperate to try and get
a franchise quarterback these last few
years um
and can he be that and so i think he's
got to kind of go he's got to lock in
um
he
cannot
like i said can't get distracted i mean
this is an opportunity he's got to go
make the most of it i think it's going
to it's gonna be telling can he do that
right i mean um
cowboys kind of ran away with that
division i think the eagles are gonna
continue to be better uh we'll see what
happens up in new york but yeah i mean
can can he go make the most of this kind
of last opportunity to be the guy here
um with all that going on and i think
that kind of pressure and situation
usually does one of two things right it
really does usually kind of um make
these guys tow the line and and and nail
it down or they again it's too much and
and they can't handle it so uh we'll see
again they've had a ton of turmoil there
um i know they're trying to settle it
down
it still i think kind of remains to be
seen if it's going to happen so i i
mandated a follow-up on this alex i mean
so you're saying whatever was going on
in the front office was affecting your
ability to to to play football and focus
on yeah i mean how could it not how
could it not i mean for me like
yeah i mean all the stuff there
uh with with you know just the entire
organization from ownership down
head coaching and and gm
it's just
it's a lot of you know there's been
historically a lot of drama there and
you know it's a big market uh you know
obviously the capital and a lot going on
and
that organization is a really story
franchise and and uh i just yeah there's
a lot of turmoil in a lot of
distractions so so to say that
the stuff going on in the building
doesn't infiltrate the locker room or
out in the field it would be crazy that
happens everywhere i think that's what
great organizations eliminate
um and the bad ones have a hard time
with now all that all that noise creeps
into the building um
and it it
yeah it does it does affect the product
on the field so i think the you know the
great organizations and coaches have
have a knack to keep that out of the
building to quiet the noise to decrease
uh distractions and focus on football
but it's that's easier said than done
alex smith here on the rich eisen show
uh what's you can and how you became an
investor in that what's that alex smith
uh yeah i mean
ucan is this uh amazing product i first
got uh i first started learning about
ucan and tried it god probably
you know i don't know
six seven years ago well you know at the
back end of my career and for me i was
always struggling on game days
uh
with with food with eating with energy
you know you eat pregame meal honestly
you pre-game meal rich four sometimes
five hours before a game
and then you know there then you're
playing a three and a half four hour
game and i would be in these like four
third fourth quarters
and just you you're exhausted and the
only thing that you have on sidelines a
lot of time in the locker rooms is all
these like sugar products just a bunch
of sugar and
you know not loving what that did to my
body you know you're getting these like
spikes and crashes and you know
obviously when you want to be able to
focus
um when it matters most and not loving
what those things did to me and finally
somebody
gave me this i was like here try this
this amazing new product and it had kind
of been around in circles and in the
locker rooms and and i loved it there's
a powder back then and just mixed it
with water
it has absolutely zero sugar it's this
amazing sustained
smooth energy that allows you to keep
your focus and productivity um
it's just a you know almost working with
your body as opposed to against it you
know for me just no no crash also how
much better you know decreased
inflammation how much better my joints
felt when i had it so i started using it
on game days you know kind of the back
back end of my career and just and and
loved how i felt on it loved my focus
uh
love that you know
uh sustained energy and it's you know i
would kind of tell everybody about it
but i was just using it i was a huge
believer in it um
and then
you know it's funny as i've retired i i
find myself using it even more you know
it's so easy on the go i'm chasing my
three kids around trying to get them out
the door in the morning you know running
them around to practices and activities
and it's so it's so great to have on the
go again for me loving being able to
throw it into a shaker and and go and go
you know and then again throughout my
recovery as well you know when eating
was really hard when i was in the
hospital uh in a wheelchair you know and
i needed fuel to recover i needed uh
energy for all my pt sessions you know i
needed protein all of that like uk was
just this amazing product that really
helped me throughout my recovery um so
it's been amazing i've kind of partnered
with them here in post careers i'm
trying to figure out uh what that life's
like but
this is something that i i firmly
believe in i played you know like i said
um
you know the back half of my career
using and and and now retired i feel
like i use it even more it's been
amazing product for me using my kids
instead of handing them you know a sugar
sports drink or something that they
think they need
to be able to give them something like
this
it's just awesome all the way around so
pumped to be a partner with them you
know try to help get the word out
because i think it's an amazing product
as an absolute game changer for me
to be able to have something like this
as a resource you know on the go in my
life uh whether i'm going and working
out and training because i still love to
go do a lot you know i for a long time i
thought
all that stuff was taken away from me
and so to be able to kind of have that
have ability back i go and do as much as
i can and so be able to have this with
me
again just kind of this long-lasting
energy and focus you know be able to
keep my productivity uh something that
just kind of works with my body as
opposed to against it and so yeah it's
an amazing product i think we got some
coming your way richard okay i highly
recommend giving it a try
all right alex you know if it's free
it's me that's why i got in this
business and on top of it you know i do
a four-hour pregame show my pre-show
meal is like two hours before like an
hour or six of my day hour seven of my
day i'm crashing i'll take it i'll do it
you know i couldn't agree more rich like
you know last year was my uh first
little exposure you know working with
espn and doing some of this stuff and i
and i loved having it with me when i
traveled on the set exactly long it's
hard to eat
but this is so easy to have it in the
shaker and and again for me all about
focus like being able to keep my focus
and productivity like not having
something to
you know again that is sugary that just
kind of feeling the effects of that
mentally you know so yeah give it a try
i i i love it sure i'm loving the
partnership with it with uh with ucan
they're great people and again i think
it's kind of a game-changer product yeah
i'm in uh you can go i mean you used it
towards the end of your playing career i
guess you know having a defender try and
come down on you and crash down on you
that's that's one thing i i just need to
be focused to see what michael irvin is
going to have to say on live television
so i need i need that help uh before
before i let you go alex smith um
you know obviously the injury that
you're suffered the conversation was
about is like similar to what you would
uh have um experienced in a car crash
and i i don't know how locked in you are
on the sports news but it appears that
tiger woods just
played a practice round at augusta
national yesterday and it's entirely
possible he's going to show up at the
masters next week and give it a try i
wonder what you think of that alex i
think this is absolutely amazing you
know for me there is it's funny you know
i broke my tib fib just like tiger and
obviously different circumstances and
different but like i for anybody that i
meet that that has broke their tib fib i
i feel like there is an immediate or
been through something traumatic like
this especially when you're talking you
know lower legs like i feel like there's
an immediate connection
um there is and and so for me to follow
tiger story i am a huge golf fan i'm a
huge tiger fan and so for him to barely
be
a little over a year out of his car of
the crash and the break
and to hear these whispers because from
what i understood i kind of heard we
have some mutual friends yeah and i had
i had kind of heard the rumblings that
it wasn't looking good for this you know
that it it
i've been fortunate enough to get to go
to augusta before and it it is
incredibly hilly it's a walk is hard
um
in four days of it plus practice rounds
like it is demanding and
for tiger to only be a year out
of
that kind of trauma to his leg and to be
potentially this far along i just love
that we're actually talking about this
rich whether he does it or not
um i love that we're having this
conversation i think it's amazing for
golf i think it's an amazing story
um obviously i think we've all we all
know tiger's work ethic and focus when
he puts his mind to it and clearly i
think
you know not totally surprised that that
this is a potential reality when it nev
it looked impossible um and it wouldn't
it wouldn't it be amazing so who knows
uh who knows if it'll actually happen uh
i i certainly hope so i love that we're
actually even talking about this me too
um but it's crazy i mean we don't
totally know the extent and all the
details of you know for him a car crash
and a crush injury and what that did to
your foot not just the broken bone what
that did you know all the the blood flow
problems you know arterial uh
problems that come with a potential
crush injury into his foot in his leg so
uh again amazing news i love that people
are tracking his plane coming into
augusta and i know he played with his
son um and jt which i think obviously is
amazing i love that he's you know
enjoying being the dad and can be back
playing with his son yeah you're locked
in on it you're definitely locked in on
it that's exactly what happened
yesterday and and again
you know you make a great point alex
said it you know he may not do it next
week but the bottom line is he played a
practice round at augusta national he
got through 18 holes and apparently you
know
um is
did did well with it and i g you know i
i i'm assuming
playing in augusta national that would
be similar to what carrying aaron donald
on your back after you get back out
there maybe i
and they're very different demands you
know for him i think i mean it's a
little more grueling like that the
four five six days in a row
out there it's just such a different
demand and again for him to only be 13
months out it's crazy you know i i was
almost two years
um and again i got i get to play
uh you know for a few hours and then you
know i don't play for another week right
um so it's just it's just such different
demands and
again
there's so much repetition in what he's
doing uh but again i i it would be
amazing if it happened again i love that
we're just even having this guy me too i
still by the way i know we haven't
spoken since then and before i let you
go i still can't believe it was aaron of
all the players that would wind up on
your back seriously in your first game
back of all the people and that that
that you i think it would like you
walked him two yards on your back like a
backpack i think i think that somehow i
remember i i took a couple steps and and
wisely went down but yeah for me it is
it's ironic you know uh jj watt is who
kind of hit me when i broke my leg who
was a three-time defensive you know mvp
and my and my first hit back you know
almost two years later was the other
three-time envy defensive mvp here in
total only fitting um changed my life
you know aaron donald that hit honestly
you don't you don't know the kind of
mental walls you built up and
insecurities and self-doubt you build up
going through something like that like
thinking that i'll never be able to be
the same i'll be fragile i'll never
uh i'll never be able to do something
like that and so i in a lot of ways it's
weird but thankful for aaron uh for
helping me shed all of that you know i
do feel like that was also the big
impetus for me retiring is because i
i feel free i feel like there's
nothing i can't go figure out that i can
do you know that i can adapt and find a
way
um
thankful for uh aaron helping me kind of
exercise that
that's why they also call it you can
right you can.co check out for more
information on that at alex smith
underscore 11 on instagram let's do this
more often i do miss chatting with you
alex i remember talking with you the
first time way back when when you were
in university of utah getting ready for
your first draft so i'd love to continue
doing this years later let's do it i'm
in thanks alex i appreciate it and um
you know people don't offer me free
stuff and don't come through
so i just want to make sure you really
don't know
okay very good thanks for the call alex
you take care hi buddy it's alex smith
everybody hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here